it's called it's been a minute
it's actually been months but you know
whatever and you notice immediately
you're like what's going on here there's
text on the screen
it's been admitted over the last few
months i've been doing a lot of thinking
and personal work now why didn't he just
come on and say that you might wonder
and just start off and be like hey
everyone listen
super casual like i decided that i
needed to make this no instead
it already looks like something that
came out of a television studio that's
mistake number one okay so let's roll it
and i'm gonna have you pause tyler and
just give some response to what's going
on here because the madness is about to
ensue let's go
they gotta set up it's like a whole
thing
you asked a lot of fair questions that i
wanted to take some time to answer the
producer inputs into the screen i mean
okay takes the seat
got to clear his throat
he's got to wait for a cue you see the
poster why didn't you apologize to chris
in your acceptance speech
um okay so just
right off the bat why all of a sudden
does he seem like he can't read
what's going on there i don't understand
he's an actor like what is going on it's
like why did you did he not i mean if
you're going to do it rehearsed
look at the whole scene i said he's got
a bottle of water box water love it but
he's got a bottle of water set out there
what does a poster say
the world is sick love is the cure stop
it
of course how appropriate so it's very
staged guys right so right off the bat
you're like if you're gonna do something
like this listen my advice to you if you
feel the need to apologize first of all
don't wait four months secondly maybe
just maybe don't have it be pre-produced
just sit in front of you don't need a
microphone just take your phone out and
just make
say it
say what you gotta say okay we're gonna
continue let's pull back up sorry very
distracting
i was fogged out by that point
it's it's it's it's all fuzzy i've
reached out to
chris um
and the mesh the message that came back
is that uh he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out
okay um
so i will i will say to you
um
chris he just told him he's not ready to
talk so why did you then go and make
this video now you're gonna address
chris wait it gets better he's gonna
address his mom the whole family if he's
not ready to talk give the guy a second
and then that's it
you can apologize to him when he's ready
why do we all have to hear the apology
that you're going to make to chris okay
there's another reason that this
happened we'll talk about that in a
second let's continue you guys can leave
it on screen too because i'm going to
keep doing this okay apologize
to you
uh my behavior
was
unacceptable and weird and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk
um
[Music]
i i want to apologize to
chris's mother i saw an interview that
chris's mother did
and
you know that was one of the things
about that moment i just didn't realize
and you know i wasn't thinking but how
many people got hurt in that moment
so i want to uh apologize to chris's
mother
look at what you're watching
this guy looks like he's on some type of
film set there's like a microphone over
there doesn't this seem very odd to you
it's supposed to be apologies should be
intimate right you're making an apology
to somebody's mother to their family
what is going on here
who what what pr person needs to be
fired honestly for for recommending this
this format again had he taken out a
phone and said like hey guys
i know it took me a while i feel the
need to say this i gotta get it off my
chest here's what's going on like i did
something stupid
you know four months ago i can't i can't
stop thinking about i haven't been able
to make a direct apology but i just want
everyone to know like i've thought about
it it sucked like just a casual you see
the difference between what i'm doing
and this ridiculous display
what is going on here he doesn't even
look like he's present he looks like
he's kind of in a fog
and like his whole personality is on
vacation somewhere and there's the shell
of a person that is delivering some
message that somebody told him this is
what you got to say i i just don't even
or he looks
exhausted beyond measure like he's been
tortured for the last four months or
whatever reason and now he's got to do
this it just doesn't seem
like a guy who came to the table and
just said you know what i got to get a
get this off my chest and feels lighter
as a result of saying it something's
going on here that's not right okay
let's keep playing
thanks to uh chris's family uh
specifically tony rock you know we had a
great relationship
you know tony rock who was my man um
and uh this is this is probably
irreparable
um
i spent the last
three months
uh replaying
and
understanding the nuances and and the
complexities
of what happened
in in that moment
um
and
i'm not gonna try to unpack all of that
right now but i can say to all of you
there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
in that moment like it took four months
i don't understand why like what is the
purpose of this video right because he
could have just said i'm sorry like the
next day right i think anybody could sit
back and be like all right i walked on
stage i slapped somebody that was not
the right time the right place the right
moment it like i didn't apologize in my
acceptance speech
so i think what everybody was waiting
for was for him to unpack he's saying
he's not going to unpack it
why wait four months and then do a pre
pre like staged video with cameras and
text on the screen and it's like
questions from i don't know who sent
those questions in blown up on the
screen if you're not going to unpack it
like what what complexities what new
what are you talking about
was it just to me it seemed like
somebody who overreacted
who let their you know temper get the
best of them in that moment when is
there more going on here if so like
isn't that the whole point of a
five-minute video like what are we
sitting here for just for the apology
that like you could have given like the
next day i'm sorry i don't mean to be
cruel but it just seems
like
what what what are we getting from this
all right let me give them benefit the
doubt let's keep going
there's no part of me that thinks that's
the optimal way
to
handle
a feeling of disrespect or or insults
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something she did roll her
eyes and then he reacted differently
people noticed
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences from
my
history with chris go back and watch the
video people though go back and watch
the video be honest about it whether
you're will smith i happen to like him
as an actor i'm a fan i think he's a
great actor i like his work i do but
there's something else going on here
because if you watch the old video go
back and watch it you can find it
anywhere google it it's everywhere you
will see
that that joke is made and he's all like
dee doesn't look mad
not even a teeny bit mad the camera goes
to her she is
pissed
then the next thing you see is him
walking up on stage
so i did something happen i don't i
don't know that she had the time to tell
him to do something but there was a look
exchange he got a message from his wife
that that was not she didn't find that
funny probably felt anxious in the
moment what do i do i gotta like stand
up for her
didn't have time to process it and boom
that's my estimation of what went on to
say that she had no role that i know the
tape says something different let's keep
watching
with it
i'm sorry babe
um
i'm gonna say sorry to my my kids and
and my family
for the heat that i brought on
all of us
um to all my fellow nominees
you know this is a community it's like i
won because you you voted for me and it
really breaks my heart to have stolen
and and harnessed tarnished your moment
doesn't these people were nominated four
months ago
doesn't it seem odd to say that now i
mean is there not a significant delay
here given the type of message now if he
had come out and said i went to therapy
i figured out x y and z or he's going to
reveal some new information fine
to my fellow nominees like it's already
what it's almost time for the next the
next award show
okay let's keep going
i can still see
quest love's
eyes you know it happened on quest
love's
award and you know
it's like i'm i'm
i'm sorry really is it
sufficient
what would you say to the people who
looked up to you
before the slap or people who expressed
that you let them down
um
this can i just tell you though this is
an actor
he's trying to make it look now like he
hasn't seen the question like oh let me
see this is it's now we have an actor
trying to pretend like something that's
rehearsed isn't rehearsed like let's
give it an unpolished look let me let me
pretend like i can't really oh what's
that question you saw all the questions
that advent come on will
again i like you i really do but this is
silly this is silliness going on here
now
come on
something else is prompting this whole
charade of this apology four and a half
months later
this you know i'm torn up to my fellow
nominees something else hap is it jada
is there i had heard that she has that
show what's called the red table where
she her daughter her mother go i had
heard there had been some
backlash that they were getting with
respect to the show because of what
something's going on here there's pr
involved is there a new movie coming out
you're worried that you may be tainted
by what went on here
it this just doesn't read as i woke up
today and had to give the apology i mean
come on
let's keep going we'll watch till the
end
so there's two things one
um
disappointing people is my central
trauma
i hate
when
i let people down
so
it
it hurts
it hurts me psychologically and
emotionally to know i didn't live up to
uh people's
image and impression of me doesn't it
also seem weird that he thinks that four
months later people are still like jet
laser focused on this
i mean i don't know is it like a
celebrity sense of self-importance thing
like in the moment yeah it was wild
right the next day you were talking
about it four months later i don't know
if people are still like will smith
he really disappointed me i don't know
if that's on the tip of their tongue
still
maybe if you're a huge wilson that's why
i'm saying
wait for it something's going to happen
you're going to see something roll out
and he's going to be you're going to see
why he had to do this because he doesn't
want the last memory that people have of
him to be that slap heard around the
world he wants it to be this heartfelt
pre-produced apology
that he never gave let's keep going
the work i'm trying to do is
i am
deeply remorseful
and i'm trying to be remorseful without
being ashamed of myself
also public therapy
like he's going through the therapy with
us it's awkward isn't it
tyler is this awkward for you
it's super awkward and it seems super
disingenuous it it's it's awkward it's
he's he seems like he's not comfortable
on his own skin
it's self-absorbed
it's like people are still hanging on to
that moment and he kind of needs you to
be hanging on to that moment because he
didn't do the proper apology so now you
can like it can be tied up in a little
bow like it he doesn't even seem like
y'all seen will smith in interviews and
like on camera and this doesn't even
seem like him it's like is there an
imposter
it just doesn't have his vibe his energy
it doesn't it's like
it's like someone set this up for him
and sat him down and now he's got to
play the role
of what they need him to be in this
moment but i don't feel it i this does
not feel genuine to me i want it to
right because if you're going to go
through all this trouble and pre-produce
it and do all this and have the water
and the poster behind you may as well
no it just doesn't let's play the end
and then we'll wrap it up
and
i made
a mistake
and
i'm trying not to think of myself as a
piece of [ __ ]
um
so i would say to those people i know
it was confusing i know it was shocking
um
but i
i promise you
i am
deeply devoted and committed to putting
light and love and joy
into the world i don't believe like i
don't need to do like the same emotion
it's like it's he's got the same emotion
through the whole thing it's like just
dead he's got the i don't know he just
looks comatose to me
the camera angles oh let's make sure we
get him sitting make sure we get the
whole angle of him sitting behind the
button it's ridiculous
okay i'm done with this video it's
ridiculous
it's ridiculous
okay i don't know why he did it
i don't know why the delay i don't know
why i pre-produced i don't know why they
listen to these pr people who don't know
what the hell they're doing again
will
you want to say you're sorry you went to
some therapy i can't imagine why you
wouldn't say that the next day four
months nobody advised you then hey
listen just put out an apology that was
messed up you don't go on stage and slap
somebody in the face like that you know
better just say something nobody advised
him then okay maybe they didn't he
didn't listen took him four months to
listen he went through whatever it may
be
does that seem genuine to you now part
of the reason it doesn't seem genuine is
because there's a set
and there's the angles and there's the
words on the screen and there's the like
odd
distance between him and you
imagine had he picked up his phone for
real and just said hey everybody i'm
checking in um i got to get something
off my chest
and it was just that
wouldn't that have hit you better than
that
charade
and these celebrities honestly like i
hate to say it but the world does not
revolve around your moments
it was a big deal four months ago people
aren't hanging on the edge of their seat
waiting for your apology and you know
what if you put another movie out and
it's a great movie they're gonna have
forgotten about that slap it's over it's
done the moment has passed should you
have apologized yes
done there have been like 50 celebrity
scandals since then that people have
their eye on right they've moved on
there's something else going on
also most people right now i love
celebrities they live in little bubble
in hollywood most people like trying to
figure out how to put gas in their tanks
they're not sitting on the edge of their
seat waiting to see what you're gonna
say in the apology and people who watch
it i guarantee you were like what did i
just waste five minutes of my life where
i learned nothing new
you didn't explain anything you don't
pack anything to me you just said you're
sorry
okay next if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]